and you were sort of humming along in
life and then one day here recently
I mean without a hitch you were feeling
fine weren't you
well I had had four days of headaches
that I thought were flu and I had a tour
on the mainland I'd heard about a flu
that was preceded by headache and
seasonal
I thought I had the flu and after four
days of headaches I went into the
bathroom and I had a massive rain Caesar
which I knew nothing about my partner
Christie wrestled me into our truck got
me down to the local hospital they did a
cat scan within 40 minutes they could
see a brain tumor the size of a quail
egg on the right sized side they took
one look and air medical evacuated me to
Honolulu all right this is a tumor in
your frontal lobe region that's right as
far as I can tell about three inches
behind the eyes and once in Honolulu
they did what they call a stereotactic
cafe where they basically bolt of metal
frame to your head and drill in to get a
piece of this thing oh my god and the
doctors looked at it and the diagnosis
was glioblastoma meta forma Stage four
so what this thing is is the
fastest-moving brain tumor and known to
human medicine and stage 4 stage 4 which
is an advanced stage so immediately they
scheduled a procedure called the gamma
knife which can only be done in a few
hundred places around the world the way
to think of it is like
nuclear acupuncture 201 sources of
cobalt-60 focused on this thing to burn
it to a crisp and they told me flat out
there's a one in ten chance you won't
live through this procedure through the
gamma noise yeah a one in ten chance
yeah well let's back up a little bit
before you have the gamma knife
obviously the doctor aside you down and
today Terence here's where you are here
are your options
here's your prognosis I mean what did
they tell you before you even made a
decision about a treatment they tore I
said untreated where are we headed and
he said you'll be dead in 30 days no
question about it 30 days 30 days so
looking at that and my I had friends who
flew in from London my brother came from
Minnesota friends came from California
we had enough brain power in the room to
you know match the Nobel Prize Committee
we all looked at this and the gamma
knife things seem to be the way to go
well yesterday it was too weak suela
geminis
they did it you know all right my
understanding is that the gamma knife
took about 90% of the tumor and
apparently destroyed it or started it
toward disruption or is that about right
that's what they believe 90 to 95
percent
the trick is these tumors have fractal
boundaries they have messy boundaries so
without follow-up radiation and
chemotherapy the doctors here said it
will return within weeks and you'll be
back where you started from so we spent
a very difficult ten days looking at
every cancer therapy alternative and
otherwise in the world trying to sort
the real stuff from the surreal stuff
sure
and basically what we came down to is
what scientific medicine can do for you
is something like the gamma knife or a
much scarier operation called a
craniotomy where they actually take off
the top of your head and go in for this
thing with knives followed by the
radiation treatment and then they pat
you on the back and send you home and
well the the other option the surgical
option what did they tell you about that
I mean they obviously had to tell you
something so you could make an informed
choice they said it was so dangerous and
the death was so likely that they didn't
want to do it unless there was an
absolute crisis and so the fourth day I
was lying down with these headaches and
I began to feel nauseated haha and I
thought AHA it's gonna turn into a flu
so I went into the bathroom and then it
was you know and speaking as a
psychedelic explorer all hell broke
loose it was very confusing and it was
confounding I I had no idea what was
happening I was having hallucinations I
was not sure where I was or who I was I
had two or three more of these seizures
as Christy wrestled me down the mountain
so in other words in a way you had a
form of consciousness during these
seizures at least enough that you're
able to remember what you're telling me
right now there were flashes of
awareness but a very confused kind of
awareness and here's what the real
tip-off to all this was art for a month
leading into these seizures I had been
having dreams that were the only way I
could describe them was I couldn't
describe them I
they lasted hours and yet I could not
describe them even to myself and I even
said to Christian my
on a few morning's before the seizure I
said I think I should see a neurologist
these dreams are so bizarre I can't
believe that healthy people have these
experience I really want to say you know
if you think there are no heroes in this
world go to your local Cancer Center and
look into the eyes of the people sitting
in the waiting room then they're not
worried about Kosovo or the stock market
there they are dealing with stuff so
deep and beyond most people's imagining
that you just have to genuflect to their
and nobility no I I can't believe that
if I'm alive
I can't generate happiness and peace of
mind out of my self and so I don't want
extreme chemotherapy I don't want wild
measures to prolong things I want simply
to do a good job with this so that the
entirety of my life makes sense because
I think how you die is part of how you
will be remembered and I want my ideas
my values the the books and the ideas
about plants to stand the test and Leary
did a good job and Wasson and and we all
are in the same communal here
I could almost claim a fortunate
position because I know now and that
gives me time to clean up my act and and
review now Anna you should walk in front
you know a lot of people tomorrow
morning or tomorrow during the day are
gonna walk in front of a car and be
instantly dead without one second of
thought about anything at all yes that's
what I always assumed would happen to me
and unpleasant 15 minutes on the freeway
and then the velvet darkness
velvet darkness so at one time you you
really did think about the other side as
a velvet darkness well or at least the
velvet curtain so really aside from the
normal regrets we all have what you have
spoken about publicly on my program what
you have written about in your books you
don't feel any change about any of that
do you no I don't I'm amazed that I may
not make it to 2012 and that I may not
lift a cup to the new millennium but no
no regrets all those books all those
ideas were put forward in deepest
sincerity and nothing has changed well
it depends on the doctor you believe the
doctor he just did the surgery said he
got at all he has an incredible
reputation like third best in the world
with survival rates and all that so
maybe he did get it all in which case
I'm the saint we're the same I just have
to get strong on the other hand the
survival rate for this [ __ ] is very low
zilch and some people's opinion they say
you know there's no escape there's
always cells left
they always return you can only have so
many craniotomies so those people say
six months to a year of life which is
really a drag to take on board my own
intuition is I'm not sure I can't tell
what going on it certainly is a weird
situation to have fall upon you
especially a person like myself who's
never had I've never been a sick person
or concerned with any of this I had no
idea there was so much more bida t
around me no there is Dante you know I
had not thought death had undone so many
he says when he looks into being fun
it's a sobering thought so that's it and
what you do is you constantly try to get
stronger and hope that no bad news comes
down the pike and do you feel more
intimate with death oh absolutely know
you spend every waking minute
well I don't know every waking in it for
the past six months let us say that
death has been a daily accompaniment of
my thoughts people don't know what it is
so they don't know what they're looking
at they are they losing you are you
passing to the great the meaning
culmination an answer to it all or are
you on an extended wing downward into
darkness really plays people given how
weird life has been
why rush to prejudge death it's bound to
be mighty strange life was mighty
strange and I'm curious
I don't think anybody would be curious I
mean it's an interesting situation to be
told that you have a very limited amount
of life death because it kind of closes
your mind before
wonderfully and you you know start
paying attention asking the questions
[Music]
and I have no insight into what it will
be but I suspect it isn't what anybody
thinks city
[Music]